it's what i like about going to church
i'm on sunday i need it's about time i
come out of church on sunday i'm ready
to let's go put some things in practice
this week let's be let's see if we can
really apply these things some lessons
i've learned and i'm good for monday i'm
solid on tuesday i'm solid on wednesday
starts to fade a little bit on thursday
a little bit more on friday ooh saturday
come on sunday i need you again i was at
vacation bible school one year and
god literally said you're gonna be a
missionary and i was like oh not me you
got the wrong
four seasons hotel remember me god
anyway um
the missionary turns out to be
of a different it didn't look like what
i thought it was going to look like okay
describe the missionary what it what how
what is it
let's go to indonesia let's feed the
poor really feed the poor and sick that
we're supposed to do like let's go on a
journey let's spread the word of what
works for us makes us happy
being able to do that and i didn't think
it would be
talking about god or the lord or jesus
on broadway or maybe on a talk show or
maybe here today with you or i didn't
even think when i grew up that it was
all that
different
because he's clearly not a dude sitting
on a throne in the sky god is love
god is love god is energy and beautiful
energetic light it only knows love
it wanted to experience love so
fragments of god are sprinkled about
those us being those sprinkles to
experience we're still connected
to experience
love and the only way you can experience
it is by having
you know things be polarized so you have
to have
you look at us on this planet a lot of
polarization but that's how you
know and experience it so that's how i
feel that we're divinely connected to
god but god is all-knowing consciousness
god is love do you have a spiritual
practice i'm hindu by religion i'm more
spiritual than religious i believe i've
been raised
religious on holidays like diwali and
i'll do the pujas that i need to do in
hinduism we have like a tangible prayer
thing that you can do um but my
relationship i think with god is of
supreme belief whatever your face of
your faith is
it all leads to the same place it's it's
a journey
faith is um
it's it's all taking you to that feeling
you know that larger higher power and i
believe that there is a higher power i
believe that there is something called
destiny and i believe in fate but i also
believe
that we're the sum of our choices
as our life goes along and fate will put
you in front of an opportunity but it's
up to us to recognize it and then to act
upon it for years my meditation i always
say the ah father
and i always imagine um
god's white light coming in through the
top of my head pushing out any gray
negativity
from my body and just like i almost
imagine myself like translucent
and then i imagine everything drained
from me being trans trans transformed
into magnificent white light and then i
imagine it like coming up through my
feet through my tailbone and just
encasing me in god's white light and
then i imagine it's showering me with
god's white light protection and all
information for the highest good of all
concerned my relationship with religion
was the driving factor to me and my
relationship with spirituality now
um because
i really struggled with
certain aspects of religion
um especially anytime anything is
monetized
you just it
by nature it's flawed and you mean the
basket that goes around with putting
money in it it could be the it could be
the basket i you know i had a priest i
went to catholic churches a lot when i
was a kid
that's all we
i went to catholic church as a kid and
you grew up in louisiana
yeah and there was this one priest that
was constantly you know he did he'd
deliver a 10-minute sermon and then he'd
spend 30 minutes with a powerpoint
telling you how they were struggling to
pay for the church
and i think that's when it became very
clear and i was like 12. um but i think
that's when i started disconnecting
religion from spirituality
and somewhere and i was somewhere in the
middle for a long time and then i
realized what i'm trying to find is
spirituality what i'm trying to
understand the spirituality what i want
what i'm craving
is a connection with an understanding of
spirituality um and it's come in
multiple forms and i think
from traveling the world and meeting
people from you know from very different
walks of life it's opened my eyes in a
beautiful way to understanding um
that there's a lot more to understand i
would say
most religions since i don't know all
yeah
share most values
but they express them differently and
live them differently and there are some
real
value and idea differences in different
religions that are reflected in
different societies
so
that's why i don't try to judge other
religions because i don't live them
and when people ask me like why is
judaism better than this or that i
always tell them that my job is to argue
for judaism's excellence not at
superiority because i never was a hindu
so am i going to say what's wrong with
hinduism i don't know
but i don't think that by being jewish i
know what it is to be a hindu more
recently i've
been reading the bible and praying which
is not something i was brought up to do
at all
but then my mom
my mom had cancer and she became a
catholic during that period of time and
some weird very strange things happen
that made me even with a more logical
mind kind of question how i was thinking
so she was just
she was well she was diagnosed with
cancer and we went to a whole bunch of
different specialists obviously all over
north america and they all said you have
eight and a half months to 11 months and
there's nothing you can do about it and
it was a very rare like
absurdly like you'd see in the movie
rare type of cancer was like oh yeah 30
people have had this and they all die
when a new kid comes to the playground
what do the other kids do do they say oh
look a new child let's let's bring him
in and give him our no they say get the
new kid um
the idea i think and and religion at its
best does this
is you have to have something
that
transcends all the differences and the
only thing i know that transcends all
the differences is the idea that we're
created by one
god that i always share that i am a
practicing catholic there are a lot of
things that with my faith that i don't
agree with so i just don't i pay no mind
you know i just take from but it's like
anything i do in my life i take
every moment for what it is i take the
positive benefits for me
and everything else i let go of
anything that doesn't serve me a purpose
i kind of let go of
over the summer
she had surgery and then the surgery got
botched and she got injured and then
that almost killed her and she was like
and then she became religious
while in the hospital
just like on the verge of death it was
awful
and she goes oh i'm gonna be better by
my anniversary with jordan which is
august 18th and it was like the
beginning of july
we were like okay
mom in a month
yeah like a month and a half right she's
like i'll be better well i wouldn't say
i believe in religion and not
spirituality okay i think spirituality
is an essential part of religion it's at
the core
my problem with spirituality is
alone when people say i'm spiritual but
not religious i always want to ask them
how much do you give to charity
because religion is the organized
community's response
to the promptings of spirituality so i
know in my synagogue there are people
who suffered losses the community brings
them meals the community supports them
the community checks in with them the
community visits them because that's
what religion does
but if i say i'm a spiritual person what
obligations do i have as a result of
being spiritual none
so then i started studying religions i
started studying metaphysics i studied
you know buddhism and kabbalism and
hinduism and i just really started
diving into these belief systems and
seeing a really common pattern
and i just once i got the craziness out
of my head all that chatter
from being a victim story and a lot of
things i started healing
there was a natural
i had a natural belief system and some
sort of higher power i don't know what
that is i still don't i'm not religious
i'm very spiritual
but it
it helps me understand the magic of
nature or just of life or existence you
know
and then that's when i started being
spiritual and realizing
that that's all there is no it was i
think it was intuition like she says it
was god that's what she says
yeah was like an intuition type of thing
right yeah
and so after that i was like okay well
that sounds pretty good like
whatever happened there i'm a fan of
i can say what how i experience god in
the world which is different from what
god is and the way i experience god in
the world is
that the world is a unified creation
that has in it enormous potential
for goodness for caring and for love
and also gives us the possibility
to be destructive and hateful and the
choice
to be better so god is in part
the force that creates the meaning of
life which is to grow in soul and to
show that you can be better and the
better you are i think the closer you
grow towards whatever god is